welcome to banana mars banana moss makes
me
hungry for more comedians like this next
one you mitzi
it's nice to have a place to perform
during the pandemic
actually i don't even call it the
pandemic i've been referring to this
time
as that year it was okay to wear natural
deodorant
guys i got youtube heckled the other day
and i get it you need a place to be able
to take out your negative energy
i get it but this lady it was annoying
she said
in my comments she said well
disappointing because i thought mary mac
would be
younger yeah i was
younger one time where were you
you're late to the game here right and
also
like i'm just aging according
to nature like i'm doing my job
you know like are you heckling me
or are you heckling the processes of
time like that if you don't like
the way the earth spins don't talk to me
about it like talk to whoever you think
is in charge
of that whatever supreme being talk to
the manager
i only work here on earth
uh can you imagine like she was probably
pretty disappointed at the beginning of
that video
she watched but can you imagine how
extremely upset
she would be by the end of it because i
would be
45 minutes older at that point
boy she'd be pissed right like um
every day is downhill for this woman can
you imagine
what else she uh heckles people about
oh i didn't like how mary abided by the
laws of gravity
and then just flowed off into the sky
during her skit
the punchline of that joke is a
middle-aged woman
growling that's me
so uh you said i was pretty good at
science right
well uh i'm also gifted at the metric
system because um i
uh in school they said well you got to
learn the metric system because this is
the way the country's going
and canada might invade so like you got
to be ready to do business with the
mounties
you know so i studied i studied the
metric system guys
and uh the problem was the teachers
couldn't just give you a straight answer
they they were always like okay kids
you wanna know what a meter is well
you know what a football field looks
like don't y'all
take that divide by 100 then go a little
bit less
wha what
and what about the kilogram that's super
easy
the kilogram is 2.2 pounds but they
could never say that
they always said think of a small cat
like oh gosh that's
art and math together guys that's
both the lobes i i can't
get both the lobes to work unless i put
my finger
in an outlet and pray for an electrical
arc well thanks for having me you guys
i literally am gonna send that set to
all my friends right now